[Music]
now the dangerous uh politicizing of the
biden doj is now as obvious as ever
tonight after the attorney general
merrick garland ordered the fbi to
actually investigate you got it moms and
dads who are standing up against far
left school boards on issues like crt
and coveted mandates and with the
attorney general even suggesting that
parents who are opposed to critical race
theory and other far-left indoctrination
efforts are quote
wait for it domestic terrorists and
that's not all because a biden proposal
that may be snuck into the democrats
massive 3.5 trillion dollar
socialist spending spree would give the
irs even more power to spy on your bank
account that means six hundred dollars
or more transactions i mean there's a
lot of money at stake there here with
reaction all of this now
in its 12th week on the new york times
10 in a row at number one the author of
american marxism he's the host of life
liberty and levin here on the fox news
channel syndicated radio talk show host
uh i have the distinction of calling him
the great one mark levin you know mark
i'm looking at this weaponization of the
doj we saw it when they went after the
very
inclusive voting
laws in georgia and they didn't go after
the very
exclusive uh
voting laws or restrictive voting laws
in in joe's state of delaware
now we see
the weaponization of the doj
now they're going to use the fbi and
what criminalized parenting because they
complain about what's being taught in
schools or coveted mandates
is terry mccall off right parents should
just shut up and take whatever the
school gives them
you know
sean i served as chief of staff to an
attorney general ed meese during the
reagan administration for some period of
time it never would have crossed our
minds to do anything like this
the
binding justice department is made up of
obama retreads the same obama
administration that unleashed the irs
against the tea party you might recall
these people do not believe in civil
liberties at all they do not believe in
competition of ideas or competition
period
what marin garland has done here is he's
trying to create out of the fbi some
kind of east german stasi that's what
he's doing
spying on parents gathering intelligence
on parents tracking parents a special
phone number that they use to report
domestic terrorists so a teacher who's
offended or a school board member who's
offended or a staffer who's offended can
report a parent to their government and
the pretext here is some kind of
widespread violence there's no pattern
or widespread violence that pathetic
letter written by the left-wing national
school board association they don't even
provide a list of crimes that they think
are committed moreover the federal
government has absolutely no authority
whatsoever to even go in to a school
board meeting let alone a classroom
these are state and local matters fully
local police can handle any violence and
i wouldn't remind everybody that the fbi
did damn little when our cities were
burning when black lives matter and
antifa were brutalizing people were
committing acts of larceny we're
attacking our police the fbi needs to
get its act straight so this is a
pretext about widespread violence to
intimidate threaten and suppress
communities and neighborhoods all over
the country to comply with the left-wing
radical marxist agenda critical race
theory genderism and anything else it's
a cabal of these thug teacher unions
these educational bureaucrats these
marxist school contractors and the
democrat party and the bide
administration they want to use the
criminal division the national security
division the civil rights division the
executive office of the u.s attorneys
the fbi and other entities within the
department of justice where they have
absolutely no authority whatsoever this
memo that garland wrote that could have
been written by a third grader he says
in here among other things what do they
want to do they want to look at efforts
to intimidate individuals based on their
views
why would you bring the fbi in for that
they're committed to using its authority
and resources they have no authority to
do a damn thing here they want dedicated
lines of communication for threat
reporting and so forth so you can call
up your government and report on a
parent and send the fbi out to interview
people
this is i said making the fbi into the
east german stasi and you know what
merrick garland has a reason to do this
beyond his ideological extremism his
family makes money from pushing this
crap in our school districts critical
race theory genderism equity and all the
rest his son-in-law is a founding
partner for panorama multi-million
dollar contracts with school districts
they're pushing this agenda in 25
percent of our schools so far all around
the country while his family is making
millions let me say it here tonight a
special counsel needs to be appointed to
investigate this attorney general's ties
and his family's times to panorama and
is unleashing the full force
unconstitutionally
of the federal government to attack the
constitutional rights of citizens and
parents throughout this country one
quick thing i want to talk about mitch
mcconnell and the rest too
we take in 320 billion dollars a month
in this country that taxes are paid
whether the government's open or closed
you pay your payroll taxes what are the
government's hoping to close
320 billion dollars a month the debt
service every month is 44 billion
dollars that leaves approximately 280
billion dollars left to pay for what to
pay for everything else social security
is separate because you have a payroll
tax on that medicare is separate neither
of those are in danger despite what the
liar in chief says in the oval office as
a a matter of priority under the 14th
amendment federal pensions have to be
paid as well as veteran benefits have to
be paid beyond that
there is no
question of us falling out of a favor on
full faith and credit there's plenty of
money to pay the debt service the
problem is there's not enough money to
pay for what the democrats want
that's why they keep complaining and
threatening they want to raise the debt
ceiling to pay for trillions and
trillions of dollars in redistributional
wealth and their marks of spending plans
that's it
and no republican should support it
mitch
mark levin thank you don't forget mark's
show number one every sunday night right
here on the fox news channel life
liberty levin hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else